attention première cabine elie vous
allez regarder ce que vous voyez dans je
vous dis ce que je vois voilà exactement
et moi je vais dire mais c'est la vérité
ce que je vais pas je sais pas je ne
sais pas devront dire si qui dit la
vérité
attention c'est parti ok donc là je vois
renault en train de faire la vidange de
sa renault au nom trompeur nous ont fait
la vidange de sa renault attend je
regarde où il en est c'est pas compliqué
d'accord vous voyez ça voilà vous voyez
ça reno le chanteur arno le chat au
jeune chanteur en train de faire là
vidal la vie dans le mois je vais vous
dire je vois florent pagny qui est avec
une plante et qui chante ma liberté de
plantes et elie semoun nous a dit qu'il
avait vu renault à la vidange de sa
revanche de sa renault moi j'ai vu
florent pagny chante et ma liberté de
planter vous avez des noms et noémie
chrono pas nibali à dire et bien elie et
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
huawei
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes souvenirs je mène un choc la petite
île et oui les tisseuses fait longtemps
qu ils cela
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
économies rapides ici ou là ici you in
the lost à doha je suis non seulement la
vie ou djamen ainsi usage
[Applaudissements]
oh
je rappelle que c'est le téléphone pour
joey starr ce que joey starr va nous à
perdre la nouvelle star à l'eau alors
oui ah c'est pas du reste oui oui au
jour qui êtes vous oui bonjour je suis
maître chien du barreau de paris
je suis l'avocat de monsieur morville
oui je suis l'avocat aussi de bfm tv
puisque vous avez insulté la chaîne
l'avocat du frère de dany boon pour les
petits fans bonne table rase pas du tout
je l'air travers de la gueule monsieur
c'est pour moi le scandale plus
important depuis la chute du mur de
madrid
monsieur mort il est trop massive et
haïlé en boule dans sa douche là depuis
trois jours c'est quelqu'un de sensible
oui et quelqu'un c'est un être humain
oui moi je vais pas vous attaquez à base
de poulet deux jambes
oui la pression c'est vrai et avec mon
bureau on considère que la pizza est une
arme de catégorie 4 est ce que est ce
que justo apte à vous avez reconnu qui
était la personne
il serait décédé deux mois
[Applaudissements]
il a dit à l'eau avec ces médias qui
débat d'idées elle y est en fait en fait
je peu racoleuse que je parle pas là je
suis persuadé que je parle là en fait
oui elie et les niveaux et libon sériba
auto merci de nous avoir appelé ou je te
fais de gros bisous comment ça va qu'ils
viennent me [ __ ] dans la charte qui
vient de m'impliquer dans cette histoire
j'ai une carrière mais d'attaqués
t'inquiète pas tout est oublié
on attend tous deux fils de joe starr
moi je vous embrasse tous et bravo elie
semoun
[Applaudissements]